[Music]  I'm going to teach you how to plan your  dream wedding but on a budget  I'm Mindy Weiss and with my years of  experience I'm going to share all the  tips to wedding planning I've got you  from your guest list invitations attire  photographer and vendor selection to  even your food selections at the end of  this class you're gonna feel confident  planning your wedding here's a tip a sip  of champagne is much more expensive than  a glass of wine skip the champagne  you're gonna walk away from this class  with your wedding binder that will have  all the details of your day because an  organized couple is a happy couple  foreign  [Music]